welcome to this video I'm playing road
from from from from some Qatar something
united arab emirates ok one of one of
those hope I'm not insulting someone
because it's a bit difficult if you're
not so familiar with that area to keep
them all apart so okay we have a night
off and I play the quiet Bishop b2 line
96 okay so probably we transpose to a
scale vanagon yeah with e6 do this is
the traditional setup with Bishop e2
Bishop e3 a 4 and so on which was
basically putting two and two grandmas
practice by the effin Geller real legend
of of Soviet chess okay be 60 plate and
this looks a bit weird because Bishop
f3a some some threatening option I
wonder if I should play a fire first he
probably can can take and play 95 which
is better for white but we go huggle
Bishop f3 he might play e5 but inside
it's not a good position for him yeah
the thing is i believe i can play d4
here my mouse is acting weird with good
weird way I think g4s cook here if he
takes on f4 I have a 5 a direct
technical strike and then threatening g5
yep and followed by 95 @ f five so g5
night moves 95-minute f5
black is black is just just exploding in
the cinders position here this one with
the tempo and next we have f5 coming
unless I have something better yeah but
is it is strong if it's probably
immediately on threatening f 6 cm yep he
went he went out of that i wonder if i
should play before here keeping snide c5
out of them out of the mix okay but this
seems slow what if i try to immediately
immediately when you're right on this
one i think it actually threatens bishop
of seven and queen age five this looks
deadly
well so he's counter attacking the e4
pawn I didn't think about that one
hmm good defense
hmm the second not working unfortunately
sorry
yeah I need to drop back here you have
always amazed sometimes people really
play like they have no idea at all about
the game and then they find those only
moves but okay it's probably not so
difficult otherwise bishop f7 is just as
just killing him Quincy force the only
move to keep the game going I just I
just threatened to play b3 now kick the
Queen back end again play Bishop h5 okay
he's attacking the sepan so b3 is not on
okay let's play this one door for be
three next month I'm already a very much
down on the clock due to the long
hesitation after Quincy form
Joe
not much not much choice of course it's
still good good position but it's not
winning or something try to provoke g6
which would kill a special
yeah I need to speed up so I'm download
time by quite quite a lot
yeah probably just look evade look see
some
yeah 23 seconds
yeah this probably won't ends too well
yeah the Sun climb morning Quincy from
Julia really cooked me here at least a
time voice check check check and check
gives us this check check
check no all right white resigns yeah I
should have played some day I should
have replied something something quickly
after Quincy phone I was just irritated
that the game was still going on because
frankly this is winning for white no way
to defend this I mean I need to just
play something else here this is quincy
forest the only move to keep the keep
the game going and I had the computer
actually points out that g six wins for
whiteout right yeah it's no big surprise
I mean how many bad moves are you
allowed to play until you're busted so
g6 just wins the game yeah that
threatens to take on f7 so blackest is
actually obliged to take so like this
and gap and it's just these those pieces
here they are not helping the King and
I'm very quick with my my attacking
pieces so I'm no way to defend this
let's say this for example I just go
here and attack like that it's a it's
just there just to win but this is this
is keeping the game going the computer
actually points out f6 is still good for
white but anyway this this Bishop where
3m is also playable but I should have
played it much quicker yeah here Knight
b6 wins wow what a crap game I just
played like this like a complete idiot
now I don't have enough on non f7 here
okay I could good side to comp evils
hear that why this is a good but it
doesn't matter ammonia in 30 seconds so
on he actually won this rather
convincingly at the end I mean this is I
should lose but I have no time simply no
time on the clock um yeah but the thing
to note is that b6 is just just
unplayable because of because of this
continuation leading to the big big cam
extra wide now he needs to go e 5 and
this is simply an unplayable position
alright thanks for watching